الينا من امام مقر البرلمان اللبناني في
بيروت مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن ابراهيم
مازن هي ليست الجلسه الاولى بالجلسات
متتاليه وان كانت متباعده ولم تنجح في
انتخاب رئيس جديد للبنان ما هو المتوقع من
هذه الجلسه
في الواقع فدا بالنسبه لهذه الجلسه من غير
متوقع ان تنتهي بانتخاب رئيس جديد
للجمهوريه ولكن رغم هذا الامر فان هذه
الجلسه تكتسي باهميه كبيره على مستويين
المستوى الاول هو مستوى رمزي سنتطرق اليه
والمستوى الثاني يرتبط بموازين القوى التي
افرزتها المرحله الماضيه والاصفافات
الجديده وهي سترسم معالم الطريق في
المرحله المقبله بالنسبه لانتخاب رئيس
الجمهوريه على المستوى الرمزي لا نبالغ
القول بان هذه الجلسه تختلف عن كل ما
شهدناه خلال العقود الماضيه ومنذ عام 1970
لاننا اليوم نشهد منافسه فعليه بين مرشحين
اثنين هذا الامر غاب عن كل جلسات الانتخاب
الذي عقدت منذ بعد منذ منذ انطلاق الحرب
الاهليه اللبنانيه وبعد اتفاق الطائف
وصولا الى كل المراحل السابقه كان هنالك
مرشح توافقي تدخل يدخل النواب ويصوتون له
او يكون التعطيل للجلسات اما اليوم فنحن
نعود عقودا الى الوراء ويتنافس مرشحين على
مقعد رئاسه الجمهوريه وهنالك اصطفاف واضح
اساسي بين المعسكرات اليوم على مستوى
الانقسام السياسي اللبناني على المستوى
الرمزي هو ما يتعلق بهذه الجلسه مع
المستوى الفعلي نحن ندخل اليوم في جلسه
مختلفه كليا لان هنالك اعاده تموضع لكافه
القوى السياسيه اليوم في مواجهه بعضها
البعض التيار الوطني الحر الذي كان حليفا
دائما لحزب الله وحركه امل اعادت موضوعه
السياسي اليوم هنالك توافق من اغلبيه
القوه المسيحيه الرئيسيه الممثله في
البرلمان واعني بها التيار الوطني الحر
القوات اللبنانيه الكتائب بالاضافه الى
الحزب الاشتراكي والى نواب المستقلين
يرشحون جهاد ازعور في مواجهه الثنائي حزب
الله وحركه امل بالاضافه الى حلفائهما
الذين يرشحون سليمان فرنجيه اهميه هذا
المشهد ب ذلك اصطفاف جديد لم نعهده خلال
السنوات الماضيه وتحديدا منذ التفاهم الذي
حصل بين حزب الله والتيار الوطني الحر عام
2006 وبالتالي الخريطه تغيرت كليا اليوم
نجد من هم كانوا حلفاء في السياسه على على
مواضيع استراتيجيه كبرى في المنطقه
يختلفون على مرشح رئاسه الجمهوريه ومن هنا
يمكن قراءه كل المتغير الذي يحصل اليوم في
هذه الجلسه انطلاقا مما ستفرزه صناديق
الاقتراع صحيح على ان صندوق الاقتراع لن
يؤدي الى وصول رئيس الى الجمهوريه وفق كل
السيناريوهات المطروحه لان جهاد ازعور من
المتوقع ان يحصل على نحو 60 صوتا اقل او
اكثر بقليل ايضا المرشح سليمان افرنجيه قد
يتجاوز 47 صوتا او اكثر او اقل بقليل ولكن
هذا الرقم لا يؤهل اي مرشح للفوز بسده
الرئاسه من الدوره الاولى لانه يحتاج الى
86 صوتا اما في الدوره الثانيه فهو يحتاج
النصف زائد واحد اي 65
من المتوقع بان حزب الله وحركه امل
سيقومون بالانسحاب من هذه الجلسه في
دولتها الثانيه وبالتالي يتم تعطيل النصاب
الدستوري ولكن اين تكمن الاهميه تحديدا
فدا بما سيحصل عليه اجهاد وما سيحصل عليه
سليمان فرنجيه لان هذه الاصوات التي ستخرج
من صناديق الاقتراع ستظاهر فعليا حجم
الانقسام وكل كتله ما لديها وما عليها من
اصوات وبالتالي هنالك رهان من الطرف الذي
يرشح جهاد ازعور بان يحصل هذا يحصل مرشحه
على 65 نائبا اي النصف زائد واحد في
الدوره الاولى بما يمنحه افضليه رمزيه
يحارب من خلالها الطرف الذي يدعمه ليقول
بان مرشحنا قد حصل على نتابع